[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24 le
mali écopent de très lourdes sanctions
la communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest la cedeao a frappé
fort les nouvelles sanctions comprennent
un gel des avoirs au sein de la banque
centrale des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest une fermeture des frontières
avec les états membres une suspension
des transactions et un retrait des
ambassadeurs l'objectif c'est de faire
pression sur la junte qui venait de
proposer une prolongation de la
transition militaire de quatre ans au
lieu de cinq ans délai jugé inacceptable
par l'organisation ouest africaine air
france a suspendu l'ensemble de ses vols
vers bamako la junte a condamné
énergiquement les sanctions illégales
rappelé ses ambassadeurs en afrique de
l'ouest est fermé ses frontières
terrestres et aériennes avec les pays de
la cedeao cette région de l'afrique se
croyait débarrassé des putschs en moins
de 18 mois elle a vu deux jeunes
officiers renversé deux vieux président
élu au mali puis en guinée alors quel
sera l'impact de ces sanctions au mali
la junte va-t-elle céder à la pression
quid de la guinée et du tchad
les transitions dans ces régions vont
elles se transformer en dictature on en
débat avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
daver d'avoir à mes côtés christophe
boisbouvier bonsoir christophe
journaliste à rfi bienvenue dans le
débat je suis également avec nous
gauthier rybinski bonsoir chroniqueur
personnel à france 24 bienvenus gauthier
nous avons également par skype de bamako
seydoux badini membres du cnt le conseil
national de transition membres
fondateurs également du parti de l'ump
c'est l'union pour un mouvement
populaire du changement bonsoir à vous
et bienvenue également
un
également avec nous parce qu'avec
docteur yusuf et diawara bonsoir à vous
président du cadre des changes de partis
et regroupements politiques pour une
transition réussie au mali également
président du parti yèlèma
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue également
vous m'entendez bonsoir avant de
démarrer ce débat je vous propose
d'abord de regarder un sujet qui va
pouvoir un peu expliqué la situation au
mali ce double coup de force de la junte
il est signé nabias makhloufi
droit dans ses bottes
colonel maïga contre attaques
dont j'ai déjà sur la base de la
réciprocité
le mali décide de rappeler ses
ambassadeurs accrédités dans les états
membres de la cedeao et de la fermeture
de ses frontières terrestres et
aériennes avec les états concernés une
réponse à la décision prise quelques
heures plus tôt par la cedeao fustigeant
le manque de volonté politique des
autorités de transition
l'organisation régionale a très vite
placé le pays sous embargo
en décidant la fermeture des frontières
la suspension des échanges non
nécessaire le blocage des aides
financières le gel des avoirs auprès de
la banque centrale des états d'afrique
de l'ouest ou encore le rappel des
ambassadeurs
la pression est donc mis sur bamako ou
plutôt sur cet homme le colonel assimi
golta lorsqu'il s'est imposée par la
force en août 2020 le militaire s'était
engagé à rendre le pouvoir aux civils
début 2022 un scrutin législatif et
présidentiel devait même se tenir en
février prochain mais l'armée a fait
volte face et souhaite se maintenir
encore 4 ans à la tête du pays
l'autorité estime que le calendrier
proposé pour une transition est
totalement inacceptable
ce calendrier signifie simplement qu'un
gouvernement de transition militaire
illégitime prendra le peuple malien en
otage pendant les cinq prochaines années
pour tenter de justifier ce revirement
le colonel goïta invoque la situation
sécuritaire du pays et il ajoute
qu'aucun scrutin ne pourra se tenir tant
qu'une série de réformes n'aura pas été
menée
christophe boisbouvier donc la cdo on va
en faire un petit peu de pédagogie ses
15 pays d'afrique le mali et la guinée
ont été suspendus on va voir d'ailleurs
s'afficher ces différents pays d'afrique
de l'afrique de l'ouest le sénégal la
côte d'ivoire le nigeria le bénin c'est
une structure destinée essentiellement à
coordonner les actions des affres des
pays qui justement de l'afrique de
l'ouest alors pourquoi une telle
décision pourquoi de telles sanctions
est ce que c'est inédit christophe alors
non c'est pas inédit ya déjà eu des
décisions fortes qui ont été pris par la
cedeao dans son histoire la cedeao est
lui au moins parce que vous avez à
l'inter de la cedeao un groupe de pays
francophones qui adhèrent au franc cfa
ces lieux moi et eux ils ont une banque
centrale la bceao dans le siège est à
dakar et c'est l'une des sanctions qui a
été prise c'est le gel des avoirs du
mali auprès de la bce auprès de l'uemoa
pardon auprès de la bce non il ya
apprécions beaucoup pensé à un précédent
ces 2011 quand vous vous souvenez
alassane ouattara et laurent gbagbo se
disputaient
là le titre de président de la
république de président élu de côte
d'ivoire
et quand la côte d'ivoire de laurent
gbagbo n'a plus eu avoir accès à ses
comptes auprès de la bceao ce qui fait
qu'à l'époque laurent gbagbo n'a pu été
en mesure de payer ses fonctionnaires ce
qui a évidemment compliqué beaucoup son
régime il est tombé trois mois plus tard
qu'est ce qui l'a poussé à véritablement
cette fois est ce que c est ce qu ils
ont été agacés par justement ces jeunes
colonel est ce que qu'est ce qui s'est
passé moi je crois qu'il ya deux choses
la première c'est que vous avez
2 vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
stéphanie deux coups d'état successifs 1
à bamako et un à conakry sans compter
évidemment
l'arrivée au pouvoir du fise idriss déby
après le décès de celui-ci au tchad qui
fait qu' il y a dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de chefs d'état élus en afrique
de l'ouest la crainte qu'il y ait une
sorte de contagion des phénomènes de
coup d'état militaire donc il y à
vraiment chez tous les présidents élus
d'afrique de l'ouest cette crainte et
puis la deuxième c'est quand à la suite
des assises nationales de bamako le
régime a dit ce sera une transition qui
dure déjà depuis plus d'un an un qui
durera entre 6 mois et 5 ans mais plutôt
cinq ans que six mois à ce moment là les
autres présidents de la sous région dit
non c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible gauthier du coup le mali et île
isolée par ces sanctions on a vu qu air
france a suspendu ses vols en tous cas
aujourd'hui pour bamako écoutez oui
c'est un isolement en tout cas c'est
voulu comme tel donc on voit bien que
heureusement il y à un certain nombre de
dix positif et pour que les produits de
première nécessité puisqu'en même
accéder ou à la population malienne
parce que l'une des hésitations de la
cedeao ça consistait justement à dire
bon si on serre la vis et si on impose
des mesures très contraignantes est ce
qui ne va pas y avoir un écroulement
total de la population il semble que là
on se re passer à une autre réflexion
qui est de dire si on serre la vis et
qu' il y à une explosion sociale c'est
de nature peut-être à fragiliser ce le
régime actuel donc ce sont deux calcul
différent mais de fait le but c'est bien
d'isoler pour qu'il y ait quelque chose
finland qui bouge dans un sens ou dans
un autre mais qu'il n'y ait pas ce statu
quo comme il est christophe où la
transition pourrait s'éterniser vitam
aeternam seydou ba dinh et alors vous
vous soutenez la junte votre réaction à
ces sanctions est ce qu'elles vont
pousser justement la junte à réagir à
revoir son calendrier de la transition
merci madame
geste avant de répondre je voudrais
aimer clean et
et rendent hommage
et puis le tout puissant afin que les
pauses en fait toutes ces victimes
civiles ou militaires de quelque bord
que ce soir et sa soirée loupé un
africain ils sont venus en aide au mali
et dans la discrétion seydoux badini
changer d'avis l'agente
non pas du tout pas du tout nous sommes
eux j'ai l'impression que nous ne nous
ne venons pas la même situation et moi
et eux nous pensons tout simplement est
aujourd'hui non pas parce que nous
n'avons pas adhérer à la cedeao de façon
volontaire ou à l'émoi de façon
volontaire ou lis pas ce que nous
voulons le bien-être et d afrique et de
confrères et du peuple malien le sauf
que et dans le cas présent
et cela qui voudraient aujourd'hui nous
donner des leçons de morale ils sont mal
tourné pour kamal fondées parce que à à
bien des gars ils sont à peut-être 80
pour cent des très mal élu donc nous ne
voulons pas décevoir des les ordures et
nous passons tout simplement qu'il me le
pays cas ici faudrait
et nous sommes un pays d'abord à
discuter sécuritaire il ya la queue vide
l'impact est cette maladie cette
pandémie a sur l'économie c'est réel il
ya des dialyses des attaques tous les
jours et pendant 80 minutes main facile
de tout gérer tous bords il est un à
bouger est ce que vous ne savez pas la
junte à travers ces quelques éléments
notamment le colonel a thing et on sait
déjà qu'ils ont vécu dans leur chair
sous la pluie par des intempéries à la
musique ils connaissent ils ont vécu et
les remet à ce qui se passe et de candas
république c'est faux s'est effondré et
et qu' ils sont en passe et on doit pas
laisser les réalités et connaissant les
bras souffrances qu'endure le peuple
malien et ils la pressent de vous dis
donc vous dirigez un droit de définir ce
calendrier en disant qu'il faudra
qu'elle soit un bloc qui venant des
élections dans ce pays à bâtir de
nouvelles élections il soin de définir
parce que c'est celle recommandations la
soirée l'issue d'assises quand bien même
on voudrait nous faire croire il ya une
frange qui s'est pas présentée et je
m'en vais vous dire dans les démocraties
même occidental souvent il ya le taux
d'abstention qui souvent le descend en
dessous des cartes louis alors le
docteur
dr yusuf de l'avoir va vous répondre
parce que lille bien sûr
soutient au contraire
et bien ne soutient pas la junte et est
opposé justement ce chronogramme comme
on dit du colonel goïta docteur yusuf
diawara est ce qu'elles peuvent être
efficaces et sanctions et répondait s'il
vous plaît assez doux badini
bonsoir
il pour vous permettre de vivre
relativement tranquille ainsi le
comptage c'est très difficile ainsi que
je voudrais
opposition à la france en une pression
par définition n'a pas besoin de
position nous sommes dans une dynamique
de nous donner la mer pour aider notre
pays à sortir de la situation c'est ci
doit être clairement compris et il est
important aussi conquis ce rappel est un
peu toute la dynamique qui nous a amenés
aujourd'hui à ce niveau on s'est mis
ensemble du coup d'état et de façon
essentielle on a défini la feuille de
route de la tension on a défini un
dilemme pour la transition et 6,6 a été
un des lèvres en ce sens hier pour
l'ensemble
ordonnée mois le délai c'était bien le
mois de février
le délai de 18 mois ces 18 mois les
délais de la transition qui a été c'est
à dire que les élections étaient prévues
à quel moment pour vous justement ce
délai en question
vit pour le même sens
donc là on en est loin lorsque la jeanne
dit qu'il faut quatre ans
vous savez de façon consensuelle en dc2
nous mettre ensemble sans contrainte
sans pression sans fusil et de façon
consensuelle on l'a décidé de nous
mettre ensemble et qui est certain par
un moment décider de la scène prônant la
soixantaine il pointe de la vie des
autres je pense qu'il ya un souci à ce
niveau et sur les sujets où est ce que
vous pensez vous êtes favorable ces
sanctions qui ont été prises par la
cedeao vous pensez que ça peut faire
pression sur la junte
je voudrais d'abord de puissance on ne
nous l'avait pas nous regrettons
simplement parce que elles touchent
notre population et notre village qui
sera touchée alors qu'elle n'est pas
responsable
les responsabilités doivent être situées
à d'autres niveaux et je comprends
peut-être que la cedeao
encore la pression sur la sono tiennent
à respecter les engagements qu'ils ont
pris parce que quand on suit le
communiqué de la cedeao c'est qui
ressort c'est à maintes reprises y ait
des engagements this mais qui sait les
arrivants qui ne sont pas punis non il
ya ce qu'on appelle une crise de
confiance qui a commencé à s'installer
entre les autorités de la vidéo et nos
autorités et nous à mettre le prix nous
l'avons rappelé depuis le début de la
transition nous avons averti les
autorités nous avons alerté nos
populations nous avons arrêté de vivre
nous avons fait de communiquer nous
avons fait des 300 de presse pour
rappeler que nous sommes en train
d'aller vers une dynamique qui va nous
amener au delà des délais qui nous
sommes consensuellement sexy et hamé
croire et ça a été ça a été a rappelé
les bons mais vous n'êtes pas favorable
à ces sanctions pensait pas qu'elle
puisse faire pression
personne ne souhaite que son pays soit
sanctionné madame personne moi je n'ai
pas intérêt à ses jumeaux
parce qu'au delà des autorités et ce
sentiment de toucher la population
aujourd'hui on a été surpris d'entendre
des appels de partout pour me dire que
les gens sont bloqués à des niveaux ils
veulent rentrer dans leur pays n'arrive
pas il est déjà un ensemble déjà affecté
nous ont beaucoup de 2,2 de matériel
détruit son groupe qui s'entend on
discute qui vont certainement consacré
effectivement d'un ensemble de
dysfonctionnements christophe
boisbouvier et la france dans tout cela
à paris pour le moment en tout cas c'est
le silence il ya pas de déclaration est
ce que paris est embarrassé par cette
décision ou est-ce qu'au contraire elle
les puits
paris fait profil bas parce que vous
avez entendu la première réaction du
régime de transition hier a été de dire
la cedeao est
instrumentalisée par des puissances
extra régional
sous-entendu la france donc évidemment
là pour ne pas donner
de l'eau au moulin de la junte au
pouvoir paris n'a surtout pas intérêt à
s'exprimer aujourd'hui sur ce dossier de
fait c'est la cedeao qui a pris cette
décision c'est pas la france est ce que
la france c'est plutôt du côté de la
cedeao que du côté du mali bien sûr mais
la cedeao il faut pas l'oublier c'est
quinze pays vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure dont 13 qui se sont réunis hier
puisque la guinée et le mali n'était pas
évidemment dont le nigeria dont le ghana
qui ne sont pas a priori
le poids lourds
nigérian mohamadou buhari a priori n'est
pas instrumentalisée par par emmanuel
macron donc il y a vraiment une
conjonction une convergence d'opinions
de points de vue entre la cedeao
l'europe et les états unis puisque vous
le savez les états unis et le canada
sont à peu près sur la même ligne
lorsque youssouf diawara justement dit
finalement ça va nous atteindre nous
maliens dont finalement n'est pas
favorable à ces sanctions qu'est ce
qu'on peut vraiment lui répondre à ce
que les sanctions sont efficaces alors
d'abord il ya une fierté malienne
d'abord il ya une vraie
nationalisme malien qui remonte à 1960
qui remonte à la rupture avec le sénégal
qui a été encore exprimée par exemple en
1995 quand un jour jacques chirac voyage
en afrique a convoqué tous les chefs
d'état d'afrique de l'ouest à dakar
comme au temps de la colonie et à
l'époque le président konaré a dit non
je n'irai pas c'était le seul président
l'afrique de l'ouest à ne pas y être
allé donc il ya il ya un vrai il ya
vis-à-vis des dévs oise de ses voisins
comme le sénégal comme la côte d'ivoire
vis-à-vis de l'ancienne puissance
coloniale le mali est un pays fier un
pays souverain donc je pense que dans le
rap est contre-productif donc que voir
la réaction du président assimi grita du
président de la junte actuelle il ya la
volonté de jouer sur ce nationalisme
malien mais d'un autre côté vous avez
une société politique
et société civile malienne qui est très
divisée les maliens sont loin d'être
tous derrière le
le régime de transition malien la preuve
aux assises nationales organisées le
mois dernier par par le régime de
transition
beaucoup de parties non boycottées
beaucoup de maliens lobry côté donc on
est dans un entre deux ans les dans un
entre-deux leur gauthier est ce que
justement là l'une des clés n'est pas de
l'opinion malienne comment va-t-elle
réagir il devait y avoir une
manifestation me semble-t-il aujourd'hui
à bamako
c'est à dire c'est ce que vient
d'aborder christophe boisbouvier c'est
vrai que c'est la clé la question et
cette clé elle est d'autant plus
sensible qu'effectivement il ya ce
nationalisme malien mais que le problème
c'est qu'il est instrumentalisé et
surtout que se passe-t-il quand on vit
depuis longtemps comme au mali dans une
période d'incertitude avec des dangers
avérés qu'il soit djihadistes avec une
précarité économique et humainement
presque mécaniquement on a tendance à se
référer à se raccrocher à une période
glorieuse et la période glorieuse
vraiment glorieuse du mali c'est
l'indépendance c'est l'indépendance par
rapport à la france et donc il y a cette
espèce de de chiffon rouge qui
représente la france non pas que la
france soit exempte de reproches pas du
tout mais elle entre dans ce phénomène
de finalement d'idéalisation d'un passé
face à un présent qui est on ne peut
plus compliqué et bien du coup elle est
présente elle est présente comme un
repoussoir et comme en plus la politique
de la france n'est pas exempte de
contradictions ça fait ça fait un effet
d'entraînement par ap de la population
malienne et je dirai ce quelle que soit
l'opinion des maliens qui est qu'il soit
plutôt pour la junte ou contre la junte
ce resort là fonctionne seydou badini
quelles sont les garanties véritablement
pour les maliens que même dans quatre
ans selon le calendrier justement du
colonel eh bien il ya effectivement une
démocratie dans ce pays il y ait des
élections est ce que la crainte c'est la
crainte aujourd'hui de la cedeao s'est
pas de dire que ça y est le mali tombe
dans une dictature aujourd'hui
non c'est un facile de dire trop facile
de dire et moi je suis pas d'avis que je
voudrais vous dit juste dans les grandes
démocraties l'état major général à une
plaque jouer place prépondérante
dans les gares décision de la relation
comment voulez vous qu'on nous dise
qu'il faudrait y faille accepter parce
que tout simplement c'est des militaires
et qui n'ont pas droit pourquoi c'est si
on organisait des fictions excusez moi
pour nos organisations
n'organisera pas parce que les
conditions ne sont pas favorables à
l'organisation d'élections générales je
m'en voudrais vous dire je m'en voudrais
si je vous disais passé six mois en 2012
j'étais là avec la junte et nous avons
crié eu un pc pour aider la junte afin
que et boubacar keita soit présent du
mali parce que nous croyons dans l'idéal
on nous a poussé on avait dit que je
faisais partie de ceux là qui ont dit
pas d'élections dans ces conditions et
sinon ce serait de l'arrêt dolan si on
va revivre les mêmes les mêmes les mêmes
conditions pas quels sont vos liens dans
les mêmes conditions donc cette fois ci
les présents à simi que nous savions que
je salue mathieu il est il a été un
acteur depuis des années il a vécu et
c'est ce qui se passe qu'il connaît et
les premières briques des militaires et
les problèmes de la société civile il a
été témoin oculaire
aujourd'hui nous disons tout simplement
une simple question quand les pays
s'effondrait où était la cda où étaient
les mois où est l union européenne et
pourtant on a le peuple malien dans sa
souffrance un peu vous trahit mairie
bafouillé à l'appeler de tous ses voeux
personne n'est venu à fond à son secours
et nous savons par ailleurs nous avons
des informations est ce qui aurait été
corroborées il est vrai que des fois et
ont été amenés non pour sauver les
régimes il l a été parce que les pays à
peyremale et les maliens à des stocks de
justice sociale tout le problème du mali
c'est quoi il nous faut une vraie
démocratie sociale oui la grande
démocratie sociale c'est quoi ce qu'il y
arrivera la gouvernance c'est que et il
sert et y serait imprudent de faire de
la prédation sarr et pierre-paul pour
dire qu en europe et je prends le cas de
la france beaucoup des dirigeants
français ont été mises en examen ils ont
à répondre à présent la france est allée
jusqu'à juger
donc son président sont l'ancien
président sarkozy est aujourd'hui
qu'elle dit qu'est ce que la situation
que nous avons vécue du fait de l'homme
politique de façon impunie le peuple est
là le peuple ou voir et on nous dit
qu'il ya une démocratie ils sont mis en
examen après le maire de paris je suis
inapte pour vous a entendu youssouf
diarra va vous répondre justement sur ce
délai puisque est ce que vous craignez
vous un youssouf diawara que justement
signé plus de démocratie au mali
vous savez madame mais ce qui est
important pour nous ça c'est le principe
c'est vrai de payer dans la difficulté
mais nous sommes sur un principe qu'il
faut que les citoyens aient
l'opportunité non seulement de choisir
leurs dirigeants mais je choisis
également comment il pourrait voudrais
te diriger et nous sommes véritablement
incluses mais chacun sa lecture de la
sortie de la crise et se comporte
cependant il faut travailler à ineo
dirigeants nous sommes moi je suis je
vous rappelle que je suis quand même vu
sans grain je suis des motifs et j'ai
été au coeur de cette crise du début
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai encore beaucoup
d'étrangers qui tourne autour de cette
question où il nous faut véritablement
en interne travailler à créer une
dynamique collective pour me permettre
de sortir de cette cct midi les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour
organiser une démocratie pour organiser
des élections vous êtes d'accord avec ce
qu'il dit
les conditions ne sont pas réunies mais
la question c'est de savoir pourquoi les
conditions ne sont pas pour moi ce sont
les défis sur lequel nous devons
travailler et quand il ya eu l avènement
du coup d'état nous l'avons condamné et
ça c'est clair les deux coups du talent
d'abord qu'on a mis aujourd'hui moi
j'aurais souhaité qu'on puisse nous
inscrire dans une dynamique de nous dire
voilà quel est le niveau d'évolution aux
gens quand les régimes actuels a
commencé et et qu'est ce qui a été fait
en r&d volition et sécuritaire sur le
terrain j'appelle l'évolution
sécuritaire sous sous sous terrain cédé
par an après tout ce qu'il ya comme
cause d'insécurité sur le territoire et
qu'est ce que nous avons fait en temps
des étapes dans quelques autorités
militaires pour faire en sorte que notre
étapes sont réveillés
leur fait confiance à la gente quand ils
disent que dans quatre ans il y aura un
retour aux élections vous savez madame
on l'avait dit 18 mois aujourd'hui on
est en train de demander cinq ans et je
rappelle qu'ils prennent pour des
arguments les assises je la perds tes
les a si certains aussi en parler du
respect du délai on en a pas parlé
c'était en parler de 1 voie on n'en a
pas parlé mais on est allé jusqu'à cinq
ans ça met du tout d'un d'un lancer que
vous pourrez voir d'alep dans l'effectif
est ça la confiance des prises il ya
véritablement un souci est aujourd'hui
c'est ça le défi la confiance à briser
vous dites donc à la confiance est
brisée ce que vous dites ce soir
oui
christophe boisbouvier la france a
dénoncé ce rapprochement de la junte au
pouvoir à bamako avec la russie on a vu
d'ailleurs des images des forces
paramilitaires wagner aujourd'hui c'est
une exclusivité france 24 et rfi dans
une partie du pays à 200 km me
semble-t-il de bamako est ce que
finalement aujourd'hui il ya un vrai
accord entre la junte et la russie est
ce que on assiste véritablement une
sorte d' afrique de ces pays comme une
sorte de deux terrains de jeu si je puis
dire c'est une expression de la russie
de la france lorsqu'elle peut être là ou
pas des états unis de la chine en fait
on est on est entre je pense que la
présence des russes en mali n'est pas la
même problématique que celle des russes
en centrafrique
au mali on est dans une surenchère de
bataille entre guillemets entre
paris et bamako c'est à dire que quand
il ya eu le deuxième coup d'état le
putsch dans le putsch comme le dit
emmanuel macron en mai dernier
emmanuel macron a réagi très
négativement contre le colonel keïta et
quelques jours plus tard il a annoncé la
réduction des effectifs de moitié de
barkan on est en juin de l'année
dernière 2021 et puis en septembre vous
avez
la réponse du premier ministre malien
chogal mag on est à new york il dit la
france est en train de nous lâcher en
plein vol puisque c'est comme ça on va
diversifier nos soutiens militaires on
va aller voir ailleurs d'où l'arrivée en
effet des russes qui sont pour moitié
des instructeurs de l'armée russe pour
moitié des membres du groupe wagner
et là les français s'est avéré
aujourd'hui oui on a un certain alors
vous avez un démenti officiel guère
démenti officiel est un démenti officiel
des autorités maliennes et des russes
les russes sont pas claires les russes
sont pas très claires
vous avez un démenti officiel des
autorités maliennes mais on a un certain
nombre d'informations à france 24 rfi et
pas seulement qui nous permettent de
dire qu'en effet il ya des gens du
groupe wagner et pas seulement des des
hommes combattants mais aussi des
géologues qui recherchent évidemment les
mines d'or sur lesquels ils peuvent
trouver des compensations financières à
leur arrivée au mali quelles sont leurs
missions et anizy vous avez si vous
voulez vous avez aujourd'hui un
vrai problème havrais embarras pour
emmanuel macron vous souvenez de 7,2 ce
tango j'y vais j'y vais pas nous sommes
quelques jours avant noël c'est pas
vieux c'est ya trois semaines il a
failli y aller à bamako a pour aller
voir le colonel keïta oui il a annulé sa
venue à la dernière minute il a prétexté
locaux vides pour ne pas y aller mais en
réalité c'est tout autre chose c'est que
la france ne sait pas quoi faire avec
cette histoire parce que l a dit il ya
encore un mois et demi puisque si jamais
les russes arrivent on s'en va mais
c'est pas si simple parce que ça veut
dire que
la france dans ces cas-là abandonnerait
tout ce qui fait sa responsabilité des
états membres du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui s'occupe de la sécurité dans
un certain nombre de régions du monde
elle renoncerait à tout pour quelques
centaines de militaires russes qu'ils
soient privés ou publics ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la france 2 dit plus haut
et fort comme il y à un mois et demi les
russes et nous c'est incompatible on est
en train aujourd'hui on est les russes
et nous et ça peut arriver on est en
train d'arriver à une sorte de partage
du territoire vous avez des russes à ses
goûts vous avez des russes à mopti et
vous avez des français à gao c'est un
renoncement on en est pas encore là mais
on est en train de prendre ce chemin et
gauthier pour revenir justement sur
cette question de la démocratie le mali
la guinée le tchad vont-ils en fait
basculer dans une dictature c'est quand
même la question qu'on se pose c'est la
question que pose aussi la décision de
la cedeao de sanctionner le mali
aujourd'hui ce sont ce sont des
histoires différentes on a celle du mali
où il y a eu des expériences
démocratiques aient eu des passes a peut
être critiquable mais malgré tout des
expériences démocratiques alors que par
exemple au tchad au tchad on est dans la
succession
dictatorial d'une ancienne dictature il
ya même une succession presque oui
filiales en europe en l'occurrence donc
si vous voulez je crois que c'est c'est
ce risque de les dictatures il est perçu
aussi par les autres états comme étant
un danger de déstabilisation pour un
certain nombre d'autres présidents et je
suis désolé de devoir reprendre ce que
disait notre invité tout à l'heure parce
qu il relativisé la gravité de la junte
en dix ans après tout il y à d'autres
pays africains où les présidents étaient
mal élu mais c'est vrai c'est exact et
c'est ça c'est peut-être un une ruse de
la raison qui fait aujourd'hui que la
cedeao a une vertu qui consiste à
essayer de remettre les choses en place
au mali mais en même temps ça participer
ça découle d'une crainte qui est celle
d'un certain nombre de chefs d'états de
voir la contagion arriver jusqu'à eux
j'aurais voulu simplement si vous le
permettez les et poser une petite
question à nos invités à propos
justement delà de la présence russe
parce que ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure c'était évidemment le fait que
la france avec son histoire coloniale
s'est comporté en quelque sorte est
assez souvent comme un prédateur
vous devrez savoir si le fait de
s'abandonner aux bras des russes c'est
pas une façon de s'abandonner aussi à de
futurs prédateurs et pour terminer sur
une forme de points d'exclamation croyez
vous que le président poutine s'il était
convaincu d'avoir commis des crimes en
afrique seraient jugés dans son propre
pays comme vous parliez de nicolas
sarkozy en france seydou ba dinh est
justement la présence russe de la force
et wagner
genevois armées russes parce que depuis
dix ans les lignes soviétique depuis les
temps les richesses le mali a des
relations depuis l'indépendance a tissé
de bonnes relations de coopération
militaire et les militaires en grand
nombre à lyon ont été formés dans ces
pays est là et depuis ces pays nous
savons comment est-ce que le moment tout
l'arsenal de guerre dont elle dispose et
les mollets a été décimée volontairement
détruits et des milk 21 qui ont été des
matelly et qui sont disons qu'ils sont
nés vers des camps à un trophée alors
que celle des moteurs des chars qui ont
déçu j'ai aimé le voir
devenir tous les signes wagner ça ne
vous inquiète pas non ça nous inquiète
et nullement parce que nous a laissés
nous tenter d'autres expériences aux
jeudi les forces armées du mali monte en
puissance et c'est que et les militaires
ne vous diront jamais on ne peut pas
mettre ses oeufs dans le même panier et
aujourd'hui au lever ou non les forces
armées maliennes sont en train de monter
en puissance et ya des progrès réels et
depuis les résultats sont là et il ya
une accalmie est un ennemi provoqué la
rage les autres werner
dubach jeff pas la coopération russe
parce que c'est des éléments des forces
armées russes qui sont là nous ne
connaissons pas bonheur à partir du
moment les autorités compétentes
aujourd'hui qui ont à charge de les pays
on dit qui a parlé wagner
dis moi je m'inscris en faux contre
cette appellation wagner et j'adhère à
la déclaration et je le partage combien
et comme comme comme cela comme étant et
elle passaient là que des us et des
forces armées russes qui sont amples et
qui sont entrés en somalie et qui sont
en train de nous former de nous et
inchallah il malicieux relève est là
parce que nous n'avons nous avons vécu
nous n'avons eu que leurs yeux pour
pleurer pendant dix ans lien il y un
ailier sondés faire confiance vous faire
confiance à ces pour établir ces câbles
volonté
de toutes tailles nous a aidés nous ont
aidés est ce juste un petit mot je suis
né s'adresse justement que je dois
répondre très vite alors oui il
nous le dit avoir agi pour y répondre
les éditions justement la présence russe
vous leur faites confiance comme vient
de le dire c'est doux badini vous êtes
d'accord avec lui
vous savez nous avons tous décliné notre
position par rapport à cela nous ont
toujours opposé à la présence de notre
territoire mais nous pensons que notre
pays quand même en tant qu'etat
souverain n'est pas défini ses priorités
et autobus à mobiliser le moindre autour
de nous pour nous aider à sortir de la
situation
c'est vrai quand on regarde les
dernières années où on n'a pas senti une
résultats notoires sur le terrain sap
est souvent justifiée c'est un plus de
positions de nos populations parce
qu'ils ont capté dollars hélas de la
paix de la sécurité et si les résultats
ne sont pas là souvent ça donne
l'opportunité à toutes sortes de
davanture
laventure c'est celle avec les russes
auxquels vous faites allusion et c'est
l'échec de la france auquel vous faites
allusion pour être plus concret et le
manque de résultats
nous promettre un peu dans la france
s'est en partie aussi de la coalition
autour de nous si nous ne voyons pas de
résultats sur le terrain souvent ça même
les populations attendent et d'autres
aux aventures et à coire est normal des
choses nous au niveau de notre
engouement notamment été aussi
relativement clair tout au tout début
nous avons dit que nous ne voulons pas
de mercenaires autour de noter c'est ce
que tout le monde dit d'ailleurs même
état seydou bâ dit ni dont vous êtes en
désaccord avec lui c'est parce que dit
l'agente quentin finalement là
je dis ce n'est pas ce que dit la jarne
justement puisque eux enfin clairement
il ya des forces russes sur place et
seydoux m'a dit dis lui que c'est bien
oui mais mal en réalité nous ne sommes
pas opposés à la russie vivement attaqué
attaqué vide politique je ne suis pas
opposée à la russie si notre état pense
qu'un certain niveau il a besoin de
mobiliser tout le mois mais raison pour
laquelle je le dis encore est la
première des mobilisations c'est quand
même les russes les ressources autour du
monde et nous n'avons pas le droit quand
même de nous mettre à dos toute notre
communauté de destin est allé chercher
aussi les commanditaires l'état à
d'autres niveaux ou de la ddc qui sont
avec nous qu'ils partagent un destin et
qui auraient été les premiers à nous
c'est courir quand il ya eu la latte
résidant dans le pays et bien sûr
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un autre
forme qui elle élève comme un jeu de dés
des nations-unies et qui nous permet
d'élargir suffisamment nos partenariats
mais retombe je les dis il me rend aussi
la responsabilité de savoir défini nos
priorités est de savoir qui est à même
de nous aider à atteindre ses objectifs
kiki pardonner mans défend de mots
clés pardon
et je ne pense pas
on vous a entendu à christophe
christophe boisbouvier finalement skin
impuissance de la communauté
internationale à gérer l'ensemble de ces
crises bruxelles enfin normalement les
états européens vont se réunir vos
évoqué également la présence d'autres
pays d'ailleurs militaire au mali est ce
que finalement ce dénouement ce qui se
passe dans ce pays et dans d'autres pays
d'afrique montre un peu ça tape licence
de la communauté internationale il ya la
conjonction de deux feuilles à la
conjonction du de la résilience des
groupes jihadistes
le dr yusuf diawara rappelait à
l'instant la communauté de destin entre
la france et le mali en janvier 2013 ce
sont des soldats français de l'opération
serval ça s'appelait pas encore barkan
qui ont sauvé bamako c'est à dire que si
serval n'avait pas été déployée à
l'époque par françois hollande bah la
ville de bamako 2 millions d'habitants
aurait sans doute été prise par les
colonnes djihadistes qui fondait sur
mopti et qui aurait sans doute continuer
jusqu'à jusqu'à bamako
c'est pour ça que beaucoup de maliens
toujours aujourd'hui neuf ans après
reste très attaché à au soutien à la
coopération militaire entre le mali et
la france qui a une histoire commune il
ya 52 soldats français qui sont morts
pour pour le mali
donc il y à cette résilience des groupes
terroristes qui fait que non seulement
ils ont réussi à garder le contrôle d'un
certain nombre de régions du nord mali
mais à se répandre dans le centre du
mali dans la région justement de mopti
et puis il y a le deuxième problème
fondamental c'est la faillite de l'état
malien depuis de très nombreuses années
notamment la mauvaise gouvernance qui
fait que cet état est profondément
touché
atteint par la corruption ce qui
explique notamment le mouvement
populaire du n 5 qui a abouti à
l'arrivée des militaires au pouvoir en
août 2020 du coup qu'est ce qui va se
passer gauthier
dans les mois qui viennent est-ce qu'il
va y avoir de reprise de négociations
avec la cedeao et la junte qu'est ce qui
va se passer on est dans un rapport de
force ce qui rend compliqué la chose
c'est que toute pression sur la junte
même si on estime qu'elle est justifiée
ça rejoint ce que veut dit oui sauf à
l'instant le problème au mali c'est la
gouvernance et l'état et ses limites
quand vous voyez que l'état par exemple
les militaires actuellement essaient de
négocier via des intermédiaires pour
empêcher éventuellement qui les actions
jihadistes parce qu'au fond ce que
veulent les militaires savoir un pouvoir
le plus complet possible mais quand vous
multipliez les intermédiaires de la
sorte
multiplier les nuances et vous avez des
situations où par exemple ces
intermédiaires pour faciliter la vie des
maliens dans certaines régions sont
obligés d'accepter en échange la loi
fixé par les djihadistes concernant le
voile des femmes etc ans et ce n'est
qu'un exemple mais quand vous voulez
agir là dessus vous ne pouvez pas agir
uniquement sur l'état malien compte tenu
de sa faiblesse il faudrait pouvoir agir
sur toute cette chaîne or ça n'est pas
les résolutions de la cedeao quelles que
soient leurs vertus qui vont pouvoir
peser sur ce type de situation parce que
au bout de la chaîne c'est précisément
aussi les maliens qui vont se déterminer
soit pour laisser ce type de gouvernance
de type militaire junte ou bien d'en
changer mais vous voyez avant d'arriver
à l'opinion et à l'action du malien et
il ya cette chaîne qui est un peu
irrégulière avec des accrocs et des
maillons seydou ba dinh et juste pour
terminer est ce que vous allez discuter
avec la cedeao la junte est ce qu'elle
va discuter avec cedeao
[Applaudissements]
le serval la venue de cerval au mali
n'en est pas une et deux occasions se
présentent héros va rediscuter parce que
j'étais il ya été acteur et j'étais là à
ce moment précis mais pour dire un pays
aux deux tiers occuper la communauté
internationale ferme les yeux et nul ne
veut pas reconnaître les premières les
espoirs aujourd'hui deux du gouvernement
je vous donne des chiffres aujourd'hui
pour 2022 depuis que la junte au pouvoir
sans appui budgétaire ni sectaire ni
général nous arrivons à tenir et à payer
personne laisser l'argent du manque de
quoi tenir mallié le double est vrai
qu'avec les sanctionnés ces derniers
jours a question que pouvoir payer ça va
non non nous n'a la cedao a fermé et je
vois je gueule des voix tout de suite on
a fait un poste où les minutes c'est un
pré situé à informer la communauté
internationale tout le mali que les
frontières sont fermées autant nous
n'allons pas ouvrir le quartier carcéral
cinq pays d'afrique il ya 195 pays dans
le monde il n'y a pas que la france que
la communauté européenne il n'y a pas
que lui moi la cedeao et